hey everybody and thank you for watching
The Wild Ride Clips Channel this is a
tough question are you happy man I've
always struggled with it but one thing I
don't struggle with is annoying body and
Bush hair because this clip is brought
to you by manscaped and I love them so
stick around to the very end for a
killer deal from manscaped and let's
talk about happiness so when did you
start doing comedy uh right before that
and then I left and that was one of the
reasons like I really wanted to do stand
up like I'd be I'd be in Madrid like
looking at Facebook seeing all these
guys from the Harrisburg Comedy Zone
which is where I was from like these
guys that sucked like getting the hosts
I'd be like these [ __ ] I should
be in there right and like I got home
and yeah focused on stand-up entirely
that's good man yeah that little jealous
that [ __ ] Works sitting at home brooding
me like you [ __ ] especially when
you're in another country yeah yeah did
negativity is crucial like I don't think
I got anywhere in life based on like uh
the the joy of it I was like dude this
[ __ ] person called me a loser this
person
just like [ __ ] pissed off and and
vengeful success yeah it's the only way
and then you're never happy yeah it's
good I'm never happy anyway never want
to be happy yeah yeah I gotta I I got
this new book and I'm like people ask me
if I'm happy the question just always
made me uncomfortable like because like
I can only react to the question just
with like a feeling and it's like no I'm
not [ __ ] happy like uh yeah and like
who the [ __ ] happy yeah and and what
wouldn't being happening accomplished no
right now
what would what would being happy
accomplish I'd be content I wouldn't
need anything more I'd be [ __ ] lazy
I'd be a loser yeah happy is for losers
I don't want to be a loser we're
extremely successful guys yeah there are
dudes like I think Rogan is happy I can
believe there's dudes that are happy
that are just driven psychos I need to I
Rely entirely on but what's the
motivating force behind like Rogan keep
doing what he's doing because like he's
already has it all like how do you keep
motivated like that every day how do you
sit in the [ __ ] ice bath for 25
minutes
I love burnt Crushers talking about uh
Rogan's whoop band how the whoop band
itself is like
yeah so at the end of the last podcast
we did with me normandari and Rogan we
started like longing beers and I drink a
lot and Rogan was like I can drink with
I can do that and I was like all right
and he was like no I'm gonna do just as
many as you like he got competitive we
probably can't psycho [ __ ] he got [ __ ]
up he was and you were fine he was
obliterated no I was drunk but he was
like
falling down for buying beers huh but
then he got back and then he came back
like two hours later we did another show
and he was yeah because he probably
[ __ ] took a [ __ ] ice bath just
like took some type of like did like a
[ __ ] three hours
so you did this at the end of the
podcast and then you're going out to the
concert and then we went to the show we
did Kill Tony right okay
so me Norman and Ari show up and we're
hammered I'm hammering and then Rogan
shows up late and we're like there's no
way he's up and he was he was fine it
was crazy I mean I thought he was fine
at the time and then I rewatched it and
I was like damn he was hammered too I
was I was just shit-faced I was like how
are you okay he's like I'm fine Shane
Gillis like you're just kidding yeah
he's ready to go yeah it's so gnarly man
I talk about Rogan in my in my book and
uh
I'm like
it's just kind of addressing how there
are certain people that were like not
down from you getting into stand up you
know and like one of those people and
and uh to his credit he was pretty just
candid about it was uh Mark Maron yeah I
went and I was promoting my first comedy
special on Marc maron's podcast and he
was like Hey dude I gotta say man you
know like I wasn't super thrilled about
you doing stand-up you know but like I I
you know like
it's like that there's just some people
who operate with the mentality of
scarcity like there's not enough to go
around yeah and like my theory is that
that Mark Maron felt that way because
because it's like if I if Stevo comes in
and succeeds during stand-up then that
maybe somehow takes food off of the
table for him yeah like maybe there's
and maybe I'm completely wrong about it
but what I really feel strongly about is
that Rogan
it's like the the opposite yes the total
option he operates with a a philosophy
of abundance like there's just enough to
go around like he just wants there to be
more funny [ __ ] yeah you know he's like
I want my [ __ ] mailman to do [ __ ]
crazy I don't [ __ ] care like he's
funny jump on the performance package
4.0 by going to manscaped.com
Stevo and you not only do you get 20 off
your order
they give you free shipping too it's
insane man manscapes.com get the
performance package 4.0
20 off your order plus free shipping by
going to manscapes.com
Stevo yeah